oh yes what about milkshakes
i like
i love milkshakes by the way i love your
milkshakes it's my favorite thing
something in common i would i would if
it was one of the food groups i would
bring on a mission to mars is milkshakes
i would too
i think we got a movie
[Laughter]
[Music]
live from the beacon theater in new york
city
and beaming out across all of space and
time
this
is start
where science and pop culture collide
welcome to star talk live from the
beacon theater new york city
tonight
we explore the depths of our search for
life
on water worlds from the bottom of the
earth's oceans to the icy seas of
jupiter's moon europa and beyond
my co-host tonight is comedian eugene
merman eugene come on out
eugene
the voice of gene the little boy gene on
bob's burgers and one of my favorite
comedians eugene merman
excellent
joining us tonight on this subject is
planetary scientist kevin hand kevin
come on out
kevin
kevin hales from nasa's jet propulsion
laboratory in pasadena california and
also joining us is deep sea
oceanographer julie hubert julie come on
out
she hails from the woods hole
oceanographic institute in cape cod
so gene who do you have for us tonight
um i have uh two comedians first i'd
like to bring out john mullaney
uh she's the star of the unbreakable
kimmy schmidt ladies and gentlemen ellie
kemper
let's do this
all right julie kevin you do ocean
research you go under the ocean and you
find oceans on planets or moons or
anywhere else you can find them and how
are they related
other than that i know they're made of
water
otherwise why does your research
intersect
sure well i study life
at the bottom of the ocean
where i study single cell life that
basically eats rocks to get energy
and that's kind of a weird way to make a
living
but we think for the things that eat the
rocks
[Laughter]
for you it would you know it'd be
strange um but we think some of the ways
that life works at the bottom of earth's
oceans are applicable to how life might
be surviving outside of earth aliens
say it okay aliens
okay so do you care about the oceans as
places where you find water or do you
also care about life in these in these
exotic spots oh but both absolutely and
and simply put when it comes to the
search for life elsewhere if we've
learned anything about life on earth
it's at where you find the liquid water
you generally find life
so this this is life that thrives in
extreme environments yeah and it isn't
just the bottom of the ocean i mean
there are extreme environments
everywhere the new york subway is an
extreme environment
i mean when you think about how life has
to get by down there um so there's lots
of really interesting examples but from
the bottom of the ocean to the desert to
the ice um all sorts of places how far
down at the bottom
like
at the bottom of the ocean yeah like
meaning how like if you're at the edge
it's very it's like that much but then
how far are we talking like miles miles
like seven miles i always thought we
used the term leagues referring to how
far oh i mean 150 years ago right yeah
oh okay 20 000 leagues
under the sea yeah is the only example i
have
of the ocean
so so let's set some so how how how how
big is a league
uh a league is uh what it should be
ellie it's a it's a it's pi miles
[Laughter]
right yeah no i'm not you can't just
throw in pie i think you're getting the
right answer establish myself as a
scientist by using pie between three and
four yes
roughly
so so so kevin
if you're thinking about the rest of the
universe but you need you need
representative places on earth
what place is called to you
so
our planet our beautiful home is
obviously covered in life
and so when we think about building
these bridges to
assessing whether or not some of these
other worlds could be habitable we look
for these environments on earth that are
extreme and don't have too much life so
the bottom of the ocean the dry deserts
of the atacama the miami
[Laughter]
yeah potentially uh antarctica the
arctic um places that are that are icy
dark uh cold deep uh these are some of
the conditions that we think exist on
these worlds out there in the solar
system and so if life
exists in those environments we can
study as as julie does the metabolism is
the way in which they they feed off the
rocks
and then see whether or not
someday with our robotic vehicles
whether or not
life exists you just say they feed off
of the rocks
they eat rocks
and that's badass if you could just eat
rocks yeah
sure
so they're eating chemical energy that
they're extracting from earth's crust
and at the bottom of the ocean you have
sea water moving through those rocks and
it releases energy like hydrogen and
methane and sulfur and there are
molecules that have energy contained
yeah and they can use that to then make
enough energy to build a cell and keep
growing so
yes yeah yeah front row yes
this is one thing i need to get past are
we talking about like they're like
chewing on rocks or uh
am i
totally wrong
so you can actually think about it like
the microbes that live on your teeth you
know when you go to the dentist and they
scrape all that stuff off i haven't been
in two years
well that's what i'm talking about
they're they're they're coating the rock
and extracting energy from it through
sea water or sea ice or things like that
and they just absorb it through they
bring it into their cell and yeah create
energy right yep
go to the dentist
julie why is the deep sea considered
earth's final frontier
it's
it's so out of sight out of mind it's so
inaccessible and if you think about the
size of our planet why is it
just down a couple of miles so we've
been to the moon why is the bottom of
the ocean inaccessible to you yeah i
mean it's really hard to get there uh so
was the moon
i can take an anvil and drop it it'll
get to the bottom of the ocean
and i can throw an anvil towards the
moon
might not work out but a key thing like
we can point a telescope at the moon and
get incredibly high resolution images of
the surface of the moon yeah but the
same thing that
but the same thing that gives the ocean
life the water the water gets in the way
of our ability to map the bottom of the
ocean on any given dive yeah
julie's looking at
a few
100 yards i don't know how many leagues
but
of
so i got to ask both of you
you both think about and have been to
these depths where none of us can see
it's where the sun don't shine is there
any really creepy stuff you've seen
i mean
i think the most fascinating part of it
is once you leave that sunlit zone and
to save battery power you turn off all
the lights you turn off all the things
that make noises it's very quiet and
dark
and then all of a sudden looking out the
windows it just lights up around you
because of all this bioluminescence that
these organisms are creating but you
can't actually see the outline of the
organism you just see trails of light
everywhere and
this is like this is like fireflies yeah
it's the way organisms who live away
from the light can communicate can find
each other can attract prey all of these
well they can just swim at a higher
depth and then
they would die there because i would eat
them
[Laughter]
they'd stay down
but i can't get my little hands on them
what does it sound like down there
so
in my experience it's really quiet
to my ears
we know this on every submarine tv show
there's this sound
yeah we don't actually have that just
just putting it out there just putting
it out there just putting it out there
but actually if we have put microphones
on the seafloor and you can hear all
sorts of crazy stuff like the earth's
cross cracking and you can that was
about an audible gasp
you wouldn't believe what some of the
fish are saying
i can't i just can't believe it you just
lost your breath on that pardon me you
just lost your breath on that that's
called a nerdgasm by the way
yeah i am one of you yeah an
uncontrolled guttural i was so just
because i always imagined the earth's
crust as a graham cracker crust
simple simple woman and so imagine i can
imagine what a graham cracker crust
cracking sounds like so when you said
the microphone can pick up the sound of
the earth's crust cracking first of all
it makes it sound very fragile in a way
i mean if a microphone can pick that up
well i mean our the earth's crust is
constantly being regenerated because of
plate tectonics of course it's pretty
important
it's the reason we have volcanoes and
everything but yeah it makes a lot of
noise actually and organisms in the
ocean can make a lot of noise just a lot
of it we can't hear it's not tuned to
our frequency so
kevin you had an expedition to something
called the lost city what is that
uh lost city is a is a type of
apparently not any longer right it's
found a profound city and uh it was
it's a type of hydrothermal vent you go
down there it's about a kilometer below
uh the the surface
and it's this
beautiful white cathedral of rock on the
bottom of the ocean these these uh this
hydrothermal chimney
stands a couple hundred feet high and
it's just
stunning and it's not powered by
uh the the spreading rock the
hydrothermalism is powered by a chemical
reaction
called serpentinization which is sort of
similar
you know the hand warmers that you get
on a really cold day to put in your
gloves
that's an exothermic reaction a reaction
that creates heat we get those on set
when it's below 60 degrees
yeah
they hand them to you yes because we're
fragile
so it's kind of like that at the bottom
of the ocean okay um so it's a chemical
reaction that releases energy exactly
and and it manifests in the form of heat
right and interesting chemistry like
okay is there life down there and lo and
behold there is so how does that relate
to the origin of life on earth
sure so a lot of people think very early
in earth's history um that the deep
ocean is a was a great place that life
could have begun um it was sort of
protected from all the bad stuff that
was happening up here
and you had all this asteroid impacts
yeah noah's ark that stuff
and you had all this chemical energy
that these organisms can extract and it
did not rely on you know photosynthesis
or the sun
so scientists are really interested in
trying to make that connection as well
and so we think a place like lost city
might have been where
the origin of life occurred on earth
and
tying it back to our exploration of the
solar system one of the key questions is
is the origin of life easy or hard
if it's easy then life will be any place
where the conditions are right if it's
hard then life might be quite rare all
right we're going to find out more about
alien life lurking at the bottom of the
sea
when star talk continues
[Applause]
we're back on star talk live from the
beacon theater new york city
we
are talking about the search
for alien life
on other planets
julie
you're looking for life not only at the
bottom of the ocean but below the bottom
of the ocean
what's that about
so the ocean doesn't stop at the sea
floor so the sea water is moving through
the crust and with it bringing life
bringing energy
and there's a ton of life actually
living beneath the sea floor that is
crazy so we have life in the air on the
surface in the water and below the water
in the crust that's below the oceans
correct so life in the dark very broadly
uh and this whole program is about
studying those life forms this is what
i've heard it's called the deep
biosphere yeah the deep biosphere i mean
we have found evidence for life miles
beneath the sea floor
and when you say evidence for life do
you mean like microbes or do you mean
tiny so not like tiny horses even a
little
or any other kind of just only microbes
not even nothing
you know there's some worms maybe all
together more than one cell yeah i mean
we're mainly talking microbial life
which for most of earth's history was a
microbial game so um the organisms
living deep beneath the sea floor you
know are some of our most ancient
relatives to many life forms that we
have here now has anyone discovered a
talking crab in any of this
a talking crumb a talking crab like
sebastian
oh
that would be and who's musically
inclined okay yeah i feel like if a crab
could say even three words i'd be like
that's pretty good crap
it counts as a taco yeah yeah
and so what she's finding beneath the
ocean beneath the beneath the ocean
does that have any correspondence to
what people are trying to find on mars
not on the surface but beneath the
martian surface uh yeah yeah and so
broadly
speaking we're raised we're educated to
think of of the food chain as being
uh
based on photosynthesis right so the the
plants use the sunlight the the animals
eat the plants and then more animals eat
the those animals and so on and so forth
the the connection with the rocks has
really that would mean we're we are all
solar powered at some level at some
levels right but this this uh that looks
like everybody's hungry
[Laughter]
but so this kind of food chain at the
bottom of the ocean is driven by
chemosynthesis
the chemistry coming out of the
hydrothermal vents and the rocks etc and
so that's a kind of new framework to
think about the food chain and we can
take that chemosynthetic food chain
and say would it work on mars or europa
enceladus these other worlds because on
mars without an ozone layer the uv
would be quite hostile to any biology on
the surface right so there's a lot of
talk that if it's going to have life it
would be beneath the surface so and we
have the water bias so let's look for
water beneath the surface and maybe
there's life thriving there that's right
and so if you go down in the surface
there could potentially be
life on mars we don't currently have a
program
to dig that deep our exploration of mars
with
rovers like curiosity it's going up a
mountain with all sorts of different
geological layers and we're looking for
evidence of life in the past extinct
life so we're looking for fossilized
microbes
and how do you find fossilized microbes
it seems hard just for well i know
there's there's actually lots of
fossilized microbes in new york uh
you you see
these patterns in the rocks
that are created by the microbial mats
so if you think of microbes as living in
a community they kind of build up their
own little cities
and then
something changes
and probably the economy
well i know you're absolutely right the
chemical economy changes yeah and that
the microbial credit for getting that
right
it's a good analogy and so um
so the microbes then become lithified
they turn into rocks
and we've got evidence of ancient rock
ancient microbial life on earth going
back billions of years
and that's amazing and we look at those
rocks and and then the curiosity rover
is looking for similar kinds of current
rover of record on mars yes now the only
problem with that is that you can't go
up to one of these ancient rocks and
extract dna or proteins or amino acids
so as exciting as it would be to find
fossilized why not because it's not
those compounds don't last that long
so you get the the fossilized microbes
but no actual biomolecule what if you
spit on it
then you would find your dna down great
that's all i'm interested in
and so
on mars we're looking for extinct life
with these oceans beyond earth we have
the capability to potentially find
extant life life that is alive today
which if we study it could then reveal
interesting biochemistry so
mars has all this evidence of what water
does when it flows right
dried riverbeds river deltas
flood plains and so at some point water
must have coursed
heavily over its surface
right a water world right covered by
water yeah okay so
so
what might that have been like long ago
it could have been pretty earth-like and
on mars that evidence shows that there
might have been an ocean in the northern
hemisphere so mars would have had all
this water in the north and that ocean
could very well have been habitable for
life as we know it it might have been
very earth-like sun could have powered
life in that ocean
but there's also one problem when
when we think about the origin of life
i'm curious if there's a separate
independent origin elsewhere is the
origin of life easy or hard well on mars
and earth
were
close neighbors and so in the early
history of the solar system earth and
mars were sending rocks back and forth
and some of the microbes that julie
likes might have been eating those rocks
and though and they might have hitched a
ride from mars to earth or earth to mars
and so it could be that life on mars has
the same
tree
as life on earth
which would not
be conclusive as far as a separate
origin let's go beyond mars now right
and so
why
are both of you so hooked on water
that seems so
[Music]
so earth-life biased
could you have life based on some other
fluids and are you limiting your search
oh yes what about milkshakes
one of the food groups i would bring on
a mission to mars is milkshakes i would
too
i think we got a movie
okay so milkshake world okay right right
tell me so so the key moment are you so
biased
well we're not we're just doing good
science um
and so the we'll decide you tell us the
reason
so it's it's not that we're not thinking
about those things we are looking for
things in the deep biosphere um
but when we
search for life beyond earth we have to
generate
a hypothesis you know you have to and
the hypothesis is
if you bring together water
some chemical energy or solar energy
energy
energy and the elements the building
blocks for life
if you bring together those keystones
you can formulate the hypothesis that
life as we know it could arise uh
saturn's moon titanic where you look
what kind of places are you looking for
well
so we've got these ocean worlds of the
outer solar system these are moons of
jupiter and saturn possibly name a few
uh europa enceladus titan those are sort
of the um
the prime ones for the search for life
there's also they all have liquid in
them right so these are these are oceans
that are covered in ice
but beneath their icy shells
exist
vast
global
liquid water oceans and in the case of
europa we're talking about an ocean that
is
100 kilometers or about 60 miles in
depth that's about 10 times deeper than
the deepest part of our ocean
you don't even want to know how many
leagues
so you do the math and it turns out that
europa has about two to three times the
volume of liquid water
in all of earth's oceans
and so if there's that much water could
there be life and that is a motivating
question that excites you yes all right
when we come back we will discuss the
search for life in the oceans of worlds
beyond when star talk continues
[Music]
we're back on star talk live at the
beacon theater we're talking about the
search for life on ocean worlds and
beyond
all right so julie we've got a a
portfolio
of of
space worlds which one of those would
you want to explore first
when i walk through the chemistry
europa is a great candidate for
supporting life forms similar to some of
the life forms we find at the bottom of
the ocean so if you find life on europa
you'd have to call them europeans right
is there the same you know how there's
uranus and uranus
i mean do people ever pronounce that
planet uranus or no yeah when you're
when you're older than eight years old
yeah you pronounce it uranus yes it's
not called uranus
definitely not when you're giving a talk
to eight-year-olds until you're eight
years old yeah it's uranus but after
that is uranus sometimes you're never
corrected
it's from the greek it's from the greek
and it's and if you look at the greek
spelled in greek letters actually but
then you pronounce
them it's boranus
so that was my quest does anyone
pronounce is it is it spelled is it
auripa or
it's it's europa europa and zeus had a
little thing okay get back to where
where you guys were coming so so where
are you where you want to go to europa
yeah so
walking through the chemistry what we
know about europa from flyby missions
what we know about enceladus from flyby
missions there are a lot of good
ingredients for life
life as we know it life as we know it so
for example enceladus ocean is being
spewed out into space and um the cassini
mission was able to capture some of that
material and measuring the casino
mission to jupiter that stayed in the
south which is saturn didn't only look
at saturn looked at many of the moons of
saturn as well and in that pluma
material it found things like hydrogen
and methane and also little particles
that suggest it has a rocky core so why
is it spewing oceans into space that's
unusual or no
that's unusual and i have no idea oh
okay no no isn't it true that the
the the the heating of the interiors can
actually
trigger evaporation of the water and
it's got to come out the pressure has to
release so it punches through the ice
and you get these basically these ice
volcanoes come that volcano is not the
exact right word but they're the geysers
and geyser is even not quite the right
physics uh the the term cryovolcanism is
used because that has more syllables
guys yes yes thank god we're not saying
geyser
we would all maybe remember okay cryo
cryovolcanism yeah cold volcanoes and
we don't yet actually know the detailed
physics of what's happening but on
enceladus enceladus is a tiny little
moon it's uh it's
500 kilometers 300 miles in diameter
and it's getting tugged and squeezed by
saturn with that tidal energy
and you look at the surface and the ice
is all fractured
and so
as those fractures open up
the ocean below
is exposed to the vacuum of space and a
bunch of that liquid water it just
essentially boils out and it may also be
geyser driven physics which has to do
with pressure but um
that's why it's jetting out because the
the ice is fracturing and allowing the
the ocean to just getting sucked into
space so there was a movie
called the europa report
in fact it's uh
[Laughter]
it didn't feel like it needed some kind
of reaction let's try that again there
was a movie called the europa report
[Applause]
and you were a scientific consultant on
that thriller is that right that that's
correct and it um i've done some science
consulting on different things uh but
when
that team came to me and said we want to
make a movie about europa i was like oh
but this is this is my baby we gotta oh
we gotta get the science right now and
they were fantastic they they uh they
actually got a lot of the science of
like the radiation on the surface of
europa that europa is bombarded by these
charged particles from jupiter from
jupiter yeah yeah and so you don't want
to send any astronauts to europa uh
because they'll get cooked by that
radiation very quickly
and so but that's what happens in the
movie and uh
spoilers it away
but i got to give some of the ending of
the move of the film because i want your
comments on it in the europa report they
do find life
and it looks for all the world
squid-like
or basically or what's the general term
for these creatures cephalopod
cephalopod cephalon it looks
cephalopoidal
okay um
how
real have you julie have you thought
about
how realistic that is
i have thought about it
i don't think it's very likely
personally but there was yet another
movie that had a cephalopodal yeah it's
an alien it was the movie the movie
arrival it's a great way to end a movie
right cephalopods if it's in that many
movies it must be a real thing right
but let's not let's not miss the big
picture here part of what's fun about
this is like for so long we've thought
about you know little green men on mars
now we're thinking about octopi and
cephalopods on europa and part of why we
went with the cephalopod and europa
report because if you think about
evolution in the you know ice-covered
ocean
and you think about evolution of
intelligence and then technology
cephalopods can use tools
right those tentacles can do things you
can be a tool using octopus uh fish
not so much right totally and so that
was part of the rationality i tweeted
recently that if an octopus wanted to
imprison a human
to jail them they'll have to put you in
a room where the exit door had three
doorknobs and then you wouldn't be able
to get out
yeah
interesting yeah i like that yeah yeah
yeah
what i'm just starting
that's good right this is kind of cool
just one of the reasons to never be in a
room with an octopus
up next we're going to discuss the
future
of exploration
undersea in the farthest reaches of
space when star talk
[Music]
[Applause]
continues we're back from star talk live
from the beautiful beacon theater
right here in new york city
so
kevin
what is in store for us we've been
talking about
doing this search in the solar system
but what about the doing of it
so what's what's what's coming up for
what's the future of europa uh yeah it's
a great question and part of what's
exciting about being alive today is that
for the first time in the history of
humanity
we actually have
the tools and technology the scientific
robots to go out and potentially answer
this question of whether or not we're
alone does biology work beyond earth
and so
think about it we've been asking this
question
forever yeah
and now we can potentially answer it and
the way in which we will potentially
answer is by sending spacecraft robotic
spacecraft no humans uh to
lame
all right we'll send eugene on the next
one yeah yeah
i am very impressed by robots
so first up is a uh
a mission that nasa has approved to fly
by europa it's called the europa clipper
and it will orbit jupiter and make some
40 45 or more flybys of europa and map
it out in in wonderful detail
all sorts of instruments on board just
to be clear exploration
generally you want a map of where you
will go next
right right and so you don't go they
start digging immediately right you
wanna you wanna characterize the
environment that you were about to
occupy that's right okay yeah and so the
galileo spacecraft was the first
spacecraft to orbit jupiter and to give
us the initial reconnaissance of europa
and then the clipper mission will do an
incredible job of giving us stunning
images and and close-up detail
uh spectroscopy to help us figure out
the surface chemistry ice penetrating
radar to figure out the ice thickness
and the cracking of the of the ice
uh and that information
could then feed forward into a mission
that goes down to the surface
where we can then actually dig into the
ice and start looking for going from an
orbiter to a lander the net the mission
after that and how many years
into the future is this right so here's
where it gets depressing
that's where it gets exciting right so
the uh this business is not for the
faint of heart uh by the way is the
first rule of science whatever
experiment you do make sure the results
come before you die
okay this is that's a rule with a lot of
jobs
so so i i started working on europa in
you know the year 2000 or so
the clipper mission
if all goes well it will get to the
launch pad in the year 2022-2023
and then takes several years to pinball
through the solar system and get out to
jupiter but it'll get there if it
launches in the early 2020s it gets
there to europa in the mid to late 2020s
and then after that we would potentially
send a lander
and that lander wouldn't get there until
the early to mid to late 2030s or
possibly the 2040s
wow i moved well the renovators moved a
toilet in our bathroom from this corner
to this corner and it took two years
so that doesn't sound like that
you know
it's um it's very similar
so julie if you had the choice would you
pilot a sub
in the oceans of europa
or would you
send robots to do that i would send
robots to do that
there most of these types of jobs you
should send a robot i won't even send a
person to an exploding underwater
volcano on earth so i'm certainly not
going to send them on a five day or five
year journey out into the outer solar
system well so then but what's the best
okay so forget the outer solar system
earth what's the best way to explore
earth is it without the people so so
what's the need to do that if you can
just send a robot and you don't even
have to worry about bringing it back
well i think there's an important role
for both in all exploration
[Music]
humans are wonderful storytellers and
having the experience of doing the
exploration of being in the environment
you're studying it's incredibly powerful
but there are situations where it simply
doesn't make sense um and you can do
this inside of volcanoes like inside of
volcanoes like europa
and even some really really extreme
depths if you want to spend a long time
on the seafloor so what are the tech
challenges going to europa
and trying to get through the ice well
there are many
name six
so arguably the biggest challenge uh is
that radiation environment so
um
unlike the deep ocean you can't bring a
robot back up and and you know
take out your screwdriver and fix it
once something leaves the launch pad
it's out there it's done
you're not going to be able to break out
the screwdriver and so you have to have
everything test
the mantra at jpl is
as you fly fly as you test
and so just get your robot ready for
that environment
one of the tricky things is that
the robot then has software on it and
it's running through programs and
radiation radiation noise hits on a
microprocessor
can cause the software to do weird
things so once you enter
the jovian environment the jupiter
environment the radiation
around jupiter could cause the robot's
brain to kind of go a little haywire and
be like flirty or like weird like
inappropriate
wait wait so how is it getting through
the thickness of the ice right so so
here's
part of what's interesting about this
kind of exploration is that the
technology exists it's hard we could
melt through the ice with a a melt probe
that has a
nuclear power source or even some
variation on a solar power source if you
had a big enough
array
we don't need to invent warp drive to to
get to europa's ocean the technologies
are out there they're hard they're
expensive but we can do it there's not
like new physics that we need to invent
and so
the europa clipper mission will fly by
then we'll have a lander at some point
and that will sample the surface and
help inform how to design a melt probe
that could go all the way through the
ice and then out of that melt probe
would be a submersible that would run
with a lot of autonomy a lot of smarts
and that's where
the partnership between woods hole
oceanographic and jpl comes into play
where we're trying to take some space
technologies and apply it to our ocean
to design robotic vehicles that are
small tiny and robust and easily
deployable julie what innovation are you
just waiting for
well
one of the benefits of working on earth
is
that it's a great thing that as hard as
it is i can still go on a ship i can use
a submersible i can bring samples back i
can you know
sequence the dna i can grow the microbes
one of the biggest challenges to working
in space is that you have to just bring
the whole lab with you out there
and so where we really need the
innovation is basically you know taking
our science to the environment so that
we can make the measurements in the
environment and get the data back
without bringing samples home
and so clipper is an amazing mission but
we need to get on the surface of europa
we need to get those samples with the
right sensors to try to detect evidence
of life okay we'll have more for the
search for alien life on water worlds
when star talk continues
[Applause]
we're back on star talk live from the
beacon theater new york city
so kevin julie lightning round here you
ready
when
might we discover alien life kevin
within the next
two decades depending on whether or not
we commit to it julie if we find that
life what might it be like
alien life
i think it will be using energy in a
similar way to how life uses energy here
okay and likely to be microbes not
microscopic yeah single celled life
single cell life okay when we discover
life
what then
is that a good or bad thing and the
reason why i ask that is
nasa has a branch of itself called
planetary protection and it does two
things
when we go leave earth and go to places
it wants to protect those environments
from our contamination so that when you
do study it scientifically you're not
accidentally studying your own
rhinovirus that you sneezed on the
spaceship before you launched it right a
b if you bring samples back you don't
want that to contaminate us
so is it a good thing or a bad thing
that you want to go find life and study
and bring it back here but so so let's
put this into context um
over 400 years ago galileo turned the
telescope to the night sky and
discovered the moons of jupiter
and in so doing
we were able to then understand that
physics the science of physics
works beyond earth and in the decades
after that with spectroscopy we would
come to learn that the principles of
chemistry work beyond earth
and then with our robotic exploration of
the solar system we would come to
appreciate that geology
works beyond earth but when we think of
that fourth fundamental science biology
when we think of the phenomenon that is
us
life we have yet to make that leap we
don't yet actually know whether or not
biology works beyond earth or it's the
same
elsewhere as it is on earth
that's right but we have this potential
to revolutionize our understanding of
whether or not
biology is a singularity on our home
planet or a universal phenomenon
throughout
the universe julia are you on the
universal side of that argument well and
also to be clear i don't want to bring
it back to earth i think we need to be
able to study it out there because of
exactly what you're talking about i
think we need to
preserve and protect on both ends of it
and so i think we need to raise a
generation that first cares about this
ocean and this planet and wants to
understand how it works and then we can
take all of those lessons in technology
and put them out you want people to care
about the oceans
i want people to care a lot about the
oceans
yes
what's the future
in your field
i think we're looking at a a new age of
ocean exploration and it's one where
we develop new technologies new robotic
capabilities to explore our ocean and
those serve as a bridge
for
some day exploring these oceans beyond
earth and so there's this beautiful
partnership where
we learn more about the home planet
while also building the capabilities to
explore these worlds beyond earth so
valuing home
your suspect
will
uh empower us intellectually emotionally
spiritually to value other things that
we find out in space
100
let me get some parting thoughts from
you guys ellie well i want to thank you
guys because i read a lot i'm not a
scientist
finally i'll come out and say it and
i have read a lot of things that sound
scary
and um
hopeless and so hearing you guys speak
intelligently about life on earth and
life beyond earth possible life beyond
earth has given me great comfort this
evening so thank you for letting me
listen to it and every now and then talk
about milkshakes
yeah i
eugene i would say that listening to
both of you it it makes the search for
extraterrestrial life uh very practical
like it sounds like it's like you're
looking for microbes you're not looking
for uh people to dork creatures to
destroy us um
and there's something really just kind
of uh life-affirming about it and i i
john
i save you for laughs
because just because you're so
well-dressed all the time thank you so
well i wore ocean blue
i'll say this
i know many people are looking for e.t
or a way to live on mars like matt damon
but i think
that if we can just find
the smallest microbial or ikea like life
will achieve something that a little guy
named galileo achieved
and that was knowledge
so uh
i'd like to offer
some parting thoughts of my own
anytime you read about a scientific
discovery in the paper someone was
working on it for 10 years and you never
saw or heard of them because they were
busting their ass trying to get a
satellite to fly trying to get it
submersible to get to the bottom of the
ocean trying to get data that you can
trust and then understand it and
interpret it and then publish it so
so
i i'm delighted to have the two of you
on on this program
and and i think of what your
exploration has
done for the world
consider
if you go far enough back in time
the academic scientists of the day they
were called natural philosophers
philosophy you break that word apart is
lover of knowledge
and if you're a natural philosopher you
were in search of knowledge that came to
you from nature
back then there were no sort of
stovepipes of one science versus another
that would come later
as people who studied life
realized they needed different methods
and tools
different tactics to understand life
than the chemists needed to understand
chemicals
than the physicists needed to understand
matter motion and energy
so what arose in recent centuries
is that the natural philosopher split
out
and then you got the biologists
publishing their own works the chemist
the physicist the astronomer
studying everything that's not on earth
so then what happens wait a minute
does nature split up into these
professions
does nature care
that your textbook looks different from
that person's textbook
no
nature is one
nature is a whole
and so what began to happen in the 20th
century
you started finding
previously distinct fields
coming together
we start stapling together previously
distinct paths of inquiry
and now we learn that life isn't just
separate from even the rocks
oh my gosh
they're rocks you wouldn't have had
unless life had been operating and you
have life that you wouldn't have had
unless you had the rocks for them to
thrive on
so now we have
is it biogeology what's the new thing
we're stapling together because of the
work you're doing
so i foresee a time
in the not so distant future
when all the scientific professions
are stapled together as one
just as nature
had intended
all along
that is a cosmic perspective
thanks for coming out tonight join me in
thanking our panel
[Music]
you